thousand six communications forum series
I'm David voorburg director of the
communications forum I'm happy to see
you all here I would be happier if there
were more of you but I remind our guests
that we are in touch with an
international audience through our
website and through and through the
audio recordings and now video video
that are archived on our site and we
should reach we should reach a
considerably larger audience than this
than the folks who are here and my hope
is that as is often the case with forums
some folks will be coming in as we speak
I'm going to be very brief in my
introductions because we have a full
venue and I'm hoping for a very exciting
conversation Robert Pinsky is the poet
who is the former poet laureate of the
United States the only one of the only
man poet in American history to serve
three terms as poet laureate from
nineteen ninety seven to two thousand
he's the poetry editor of the online
journal slate he teaches in the writing
program at Boston University and is the
author of a series of remarkable books
of poetry of which the most recent is
Jersey rain and then a forthcoming
chapbook about to appear I think later
this month or next month called first
things to hand one of his most recent
publications which we will have a chance
to talk about a bit later in our
conversation is a very interesting in
some ways surprising book for Robert
Pinsky a book called the life of David
it's not about me however it's about the
biblical King David much to my dismay
when he told me in it also sitting at a
dark at our ad are at our conversation
table is my colleague from MIT Todd mock
over he's the head of the media labs
hyper instruments and opera of the
future group he's the creator of the toy
symphony and international music
performance and education project and is
kind of a legend at MIT for his
imaginative way of bringing a classical
attitudes toward music together with new
technologies and with experimental forms
of various kinds we're going to begin
today
by showing a fragment of an opera that
Pinsky and mac / have collaborated on
and then they will talk about it and I
thought I would just quickly just show
you a little bit about the operon then
we'll show you a couple of minutes of it
call death and the powers and Robert and
I I called Robert out of the blue to see
if you might want to collaborate on a
project several years ago and my god he
said yes it's been a very very
interesting project it's still in
process Robert finished the libretto
about four or five months ago and so
I've started on the music it's a quite a
wild project it will tell you a little
bit about the story later it's about a
man joined trying to say two words about
what the story us he's a billionaire
sort of a Rupert Murdoch hyphen Walt
Disney character he's a creative
billionaire who is getting it kind of
like Robert you know it's kind of
emortality by having himself converted
into software he's leaving the meat
machine and he's basically abstracting
himself and this has implications for
his family may or may not follow him
into this state and also because he's so
rich for the world the world economy and
there's some time was a robot pageant
the whole show is put on by robots and
our robots won't look like any robots
you've ever seen and in fact the biggest
robot of all is as the set itself
because one of the ideas is that this
character Simon powers decides that he
wants to leave everything about himself
in the world even though he himself
wants to leave so he turns himself into
his environment and the stage itself is
a big robot it's made up of gigantic
panels that move into different
configurations as you can see the
panel's themselves look like a room at
first and then they start to vibrate and
undulate in fact the floor does as well
all the surfaces that you wouldn't
expect come alive and somehow where
they're going to make this
stage sing haven't quite figured that
out yet but characters all kinds of
unusual things happen with the
characters as well so objects that
usually stay on the ground like grand
pianos don't they float as well so this
is a scene with the third wife Evie who
floats and dances with Simon in the
walls and the piano plays while it's in
the air this is my favorite shot so far
of the animation of the set because it
also the whole thing explodes and goes
on to the audience don't sit in the
front row for that one we'll see and
we're also collaborating with a few
other wonderful people on this project
Cynthia Brazil who works here in the
media lab is designing the robotics for
the set and for a variety of objects
Randy whiner who's a writer and
dramaturg worked very closely with
Robert to help craft the story the
story's Roberts but to get it just right
for an opera Randy was extremely helpful
Diane Paulus is the theatrical director
wonderful young new york-based director
who is exceptional because she's very
well known for her classical opera
Mozart and monteverdi in particular she
also has a variety of kind of cult hit
off-broadway shows in New York that have
been running for a long time the donkey
shows one of them if you've heard of it
and she also designs a lot of the
theatricals for Disney these days and
Alex McDowell is the designer he's the
one who's helping us figure out how to
make these walls feel like they're alive
he's one of the very best Hollywood film
designers right now he designs all of
Spielberg's movies including Minority
Report the terminal and also does tim
burton's movie so he did charlie and the
chocolate factory and corpse bride if
you've heard of those so we are starting
to make this project now it opens in two
years in Monte Carlo I'm starting to
compose the music we're designing the
sets and building everything and we put
on a little sneak preview which we're
going to show you a teeny bit of right
now in Monte Carlo in the fall if you
look at the top left the characters
these are the four main characters the
person on the all the way on the left is
Evie the third wife in the black dress
she's sung by Elizabeth koi who was a
boston-based mezzo-soprano the person
next to her to her left holding the
wheelchair is Nicholas who
was a kind of grad student scientist
assistant to Simon powers and he's the
one who has to know how it actually
build this system and his role is sun by
the tenor Brian Groman next him is Simon
powers the main character with the white
shirt his sleeves rolled up he's sung by
the baritone James Madalena great singer
who if any of you have seen any of John
Adams operas he originated the role of
Richard Nixon and Nixon and China for
instance and on the end wearing the
black shirt and the skirt is Miranda the
daughter was about 12 years old and
she's sung by remarkable young singer
and 18 year old on New Yorker freshman
at Manhattan School of Music named
Elizabeth writer so now I'll just let's
give you a tiny glimpse of what this is
going to be like this is a the simplest
possible set no set at all just the
performers and I put together a little
three minute excerpt so you can hear it
so to make that louder please
ah
Oh
i guess i should say i don't get out
good huh well I don't see why kiss it
yeah really great way to start what do
you feel as it would have a vivere David
more if Todd for the compression is he
edited out my favorite part right at the
beginning there the first words that
disguise things are the beginning of the
age of 72 Byzantium he says one side of
nature i will never take my bodily form
from any natural thing they says the
Dada da-da-da-da-da-da the immortal
william butler yeats with his bird and
he says something like mechanical
parakeet yeah mechanical parakeet he
says golden amylin a mechanical parakeet
and then he says yates you can have your
bird yates and you edited out the part
where then Jimmy Matt Olynyk says Yates
I give you the bird and I don't know if
that was your delicacy Todd but for the
I want an audience like David that would
have yeah that's really we took out the
obscenities for now but I said it's not
it's an interesting and in some ways one
would think of it as poorly a
problematic collaboration between
someone who spends his time worrying
about the nuances of vowel sounds and
consonant sounds at the end of words and
then having it translated into this
environment in which people sing it it's
surrounded by music for me there's a
kind of freedom in the composition I
knew that Todd was going to set these
things to music I don't have a wide
knowledge of modern music actually did
know Todd's music and as you can tell
it's quite melodic
and emotional and it really is very
referential for me it's referential to
all kinds of familiar music so that it's
an exciting feeling for me thank God
will have supertitles my main problem
with it is that as with heavy metal
music as with many kinds of music it's
hard to understand the words and I have
never liked the art song if I know the
poem as you say I'm thinking about the
original music that is built into the
vowels and usually the less I know the
poem the better I like the art song and
in this case I had the freedom of an
effect writing for this format and I
could I could throw in rhymes and false
rons and little iterations and feel it
was like playing was like a it was the
freedom of rather new medium so as a way
of composing I had no confidence in my
ability to make a good story for the
stage and that's where Randy whiner was
very useful almost as my psychiatrist
make this work I had the what Todd is
done with the words is very beautiful to
me very expressive and it was not I was
not saying goodbye to poetry i can write
a poem whenever I like or whenever I can
it was adding this other kind of
composition which I found very
liberating very pleasurable talk a
little bit about the sequence of the
work Robert did all his work first and
then you work from that text is that
yeah but usually so I have always liked
not just like but I think I write best
to text and I probably right melody more
naturally than other things as well and
so i'm also very inspired by text so I
for a piece like this I thought a lot
about it had many many ideas but nothing
was absolutely specific until I saw not
just saw some words but saw the words so
but Robert and I spent a huge amount of
time to get
over those you know a few years actually
talking about the story and talking
about specific text and then you know
sometimes we work together sometimes
Robert work with Randy but I didn't
write a note of music until again not
until there were sections but I usually
like to imagine the whole shape of a
thing and the personality of a piece and
of these characters so I got the whole
libretto and then really dug in that's
when I started writing I do hope the
people i mean i think the sound system
in here is awful i might be my goal i
think the text lights ain't that great
either but yes there's a lot of vestnik
humor political illusions Todd is
leaving out a false start in which we
wrote an aria is like one full start we
went to Monaco we had a soprano who sang
the area at the for the people in Monaco
and with that false start and with this
project so far Todd will email me and
say something like there are a lot of
syllables right here can you find a way
to use fewer and I pride myself because
the music requires of course the
exigencies of needed to compose music
for it is that a fair paraphrase I'm
sorry for getting me things like that
yeah there's a simpler word here instead
of a longer worth simpler world long
word i know you just never you know you
never know what's gonna come up in sport
of anchoring and i think in every case
i've responded by saying no but this
that is in every case i said well not
that fix but how about this fix and i
think the fixes have been appropriate
yeah yeah i think i often it goes back a
few times but yeah so there has been a
process of collaboration on that level
where this won't work here like this can
we try that let's say well a wasn't any
good be wasn't any good how about be
prime or see ya and i think i think
probably that's the way you like to work
but especially with a project like this
where it's not a fixed poem it's it's
also incredibly liberating for me
because you can start writing the music
and
see where I remember something that came
up in this section was it's not always
easy ahead of time I think in the old
days you could plan out the structure of
an opera and say okay I need a trio here
and I need to do it here and here we
bring everybody in this I think was more
fluid we knew we're setting up
characters and situations but as I'm
writing it you know you say well here's
a place we really do have to have these
people be together he made a quartet out
of what had been part of a monologue I
remember now there was things that Simon
said and we just changed in a little and
we made them you got a little glimpse of
some of the we didn't quite get the
quartet but we got a trio material and
what it does become a quartet it right
before the close of the sea yeah and
when you heard that trio you were
hearing words that I had originally
written for one character partly because
I am a complete beginner at doing this
and it didn't take us long to turn it
into a tree how long do you think the
entire project will how long will the
production date you think oh you'll wake
up and you'll be so lose two minutes I'm
sure that's not him now you might have
hard time our goal is I've done
different kinds of opera it only happens
when I read your palm the goal is to
have no intermission so you know you
can't have more than eight or nine hours
something I no no it's about probably an
hour and a half without a break is the
idea maybe it may be a little longer
meets now again now that we're starting
when you look at the text it reads
quickly it's very elegant beautiful but
when you know when you spend time with
it and make these characters real
there's there's a lot going on and there
were a lot of changes and characters a
lot of a lot of beautiful words you
don't want to just run through see there
are links to this project on the
communications forum website and I
assume Todd also from from your own
website I think it probably are so those
of you who want to sort of pursue this a
lot more find out more about this
project it civility have you have we
been able to put anything online yet of
the fragments that you've completed no I
haven't haven't wanted to put those
online yet but
there's some good text on the Opera
online and pictures and there's a amount
of set design wonderful graphics working
on them again next week so I would say
pretty soon they'll be actually I'll
probably put up a website on this I
don't like putting excerpts of things
that aren't finished I usually don't
like to make public there's something
about collaboration and it sounds like
the website does dramatize these
different elements that are coming
together I'm thrilled when I first hear
the music and I was thrilled when I saw
alex's set designs and Alex really is
very very good and when I first saw
those walls breathe and when we started
talking about things floating and that
their ways to do it and that then this
whole it's an organism that is an
expression of this man's consciousness
and then when it goes all and all goes
out over the audience and it can be done
and the robots can be done oh sorry now
we're trying the robots they're not
going to look like a stainless steel
department store dummies they're not
going to look like Robert the robot or
some post-war Japanese thing they're
largely made of light and they come on
as one thing and they have lights on and
then they'd evolve into the separate
robots who will become the characters
actually you didn't say anything about
the robot prologue am I just that's a
pretty unusual in the robot prologue
they say they come out robot prolong
with a head robot after they come apart
the head robot says or sings well the
human creators did instruct us human
creators back in the organic age
instructed us to perform this certain
times and so we're going to do it and
one of the other robot says but I don't
get it this thing death its best they're
so important it's it like lost data but
there's always data can always be
recovered I don't get it says it doesn't
matter we're going to do it and then
they discuss it and then they gradually
become the sing
we're going to say then you delight it
makes it possible and do that then at
the end after our big finish they re
coalesce but before there be one of the
robot says was that it ah I still don't
really understand why we did this what
is that about and the head robot says I
know what you mean but everybody who
participates gets ten thousand human
rights credits and they turn back into
this Thanks so there's a backstory that
is partly filled them which is where did
we go where did the human creators go
and what form of quote life and quote is
persisting in the form of these robots
who are performing basically a kind of
ritual as with the origins of drama and
a thing we've arrived that for that is
that when the robots say this to one
another there'll be super titles where
you get it in English but they're
speaking robot to one another so they
say smartnet and founded dork and fasten
state written stewed the city's British
to endure and Latin why much for Steven
for statement autumn Jordan gourd not
invested student Devon I'll fry from
stated and then you're hitting that
maybe we should continue like this it's
actually it's actually very interested
so if you I know who no robot were left
right right the native robot speakers
won't find this that interesting Todd
thank you very much it looks like a
wonderful project and we thank you for
taking part today thank you here we
premiere this in about two years so
we'll let you know come to Monte Carlo
and threaten store it'll Bend you can
see you there
favorite we're going to what we're going
to try to have a conversation for about
another half hour and then we'll open
the floor to general discussion I
thought the conversation would be
helpful because we could cover a number
of aspects of Pinsky's immensely diverse
intimidatingly diverse portfolio and one
of the most important aspects of his
recent work has has been another form of
outreach that I'm sure many of you know
about and Robert and I have talked about
it many times it's it's a I guess it's a
project that he started when he was the
poet laureate and i'll let him describe
it it's the favorite poem project and
we're going to have a clip or two to
show you you talk a little about it
Robert I invited Americans to write me a
letter or an email saying the title and
author of a poem that the person writing
loved and would be willing to read for
national archive my advertising budget
was about seven dollars I received tens
of thousands of responses there is a
book for sale outside called an
invitation to poetry it has a DVD in the
back that has about 25 of the video
segments baddam which come back to show
you a couple and if anybody here teaches
or knows a teacher I really urge you to
buy the book if only for the DVD I think
you'll see what I mean you want to do
the women first well look at a couple of
the of the segments on that DVD that is
in the back of the back of the book and
yeah why not start with a sort of a
flagship wanted track track six these
are baby 4minute three-minute video
segments
my name is John Doherty from braintree
massachusetts 34 years old and I'm a
construction worker for the Boston gas
company we do outside construction work
providing natural gas for residents so
businesses so a lot of digging laying
pipelines as it live s means all outdoor
work the satisfying thing about the job
is you're working with a dangerous
element really so it's it's important to
be exact and everything you do certainly
don't want to leave any kind of a gas
leak behind so you know you have to be
careful you have to pay attention poetry
was was definitely intimidating
initially it just looked like a lot of
words in that were out of otter and out
of place and did not belong together and
that's that's the challenge of it it
just takes a lot of reading and
rereading to grasp it but once you do
once you come to understand it you've
achieved something so now you feel good
song of myself as a poem that I probably
had a lot of difficulty understanding
the first time and there were certain
lines that caught me and that I liked
and when I got to the very end of this
very long poem the last half dozen lines
so encouraging he in those last few
lines Whitman tells you what you're
thinking he says that you probably
didn't understand what you just read but
stay with it and you will and you'll
love it and so it felt like it was
speaking directly to me when I first
read it and I keep those lines in mind
no matter what I read now
the connection I feel with while
Whitman's poem song of myself is not due
to the fact that he talks about laborers
physical labor working outside and like
the Common working American that's a
nice touch in it of course but I enjoyed
it for it's it's uplifting miss its its
ability to inspire me and see things in
life and in everyday existence that I
hadn't noticed before that I might have
taken it for granted before
song of myself by Walt Whitman
there is that in me I do not know what
it is but I know it is in me wrenched
and sweaty calm and cool then my body
becomes I sleep I sleep long I do not
know it it is without name it is a word
unsaid it is not in any dictionary
utterance symbol something its wings on
more than the earth I swing on to it the
creation is the friend who is embracing
awake see perhaps I might tell more
outlines I plead for my brothers and
sisters do you see all my brothers and
sisters it is not chaos or death it is
formed Union plan it is eternal life it
is happiness
the spotted Hawk swoops by and accuses
me he complains at my Gavin by loitering
I too am NOT a bit tamed I to him
untranslatable I saw my barbaric yawp
over the roofs of the world the last
Scout of day holds back for me it flings
my likeness after the rest and true is
any on the shadowed wilds it coaxes me
to the vapor and the dusk I depart as
air I shake my white locks at the
runaway Sun aya fuse my flesh and eddies
and drift in lacy Jags i bequeath myself
to the dirt to grow from the grass I
love if you want me again look from the
under your boot soles you will hardly
know who I am or what I mean but I shall
be good health to nevertheless and
filter on Fabio blood failing to fetch
me at first keep encouraged missing me
one place search another I stop
somewhere waiting for you thank you we
have some other lights come up could we
see the audience the filmmaker the
filmmakers were independent producer
directors around the country so we
didn't have to pay transportation costs
we brought them here for a film school
and my executive producer Juanita
Anderson told them about library of
shots what kind of video they're going
to use lenses and I talked to them about
the project and we had a favorite poem
reading at BU which we had a college
president and a grade-school kid and a
high school kid and an art director and
an elderly person we had her reading
with the kind of range which we can't
demonstrate with one video but the point
is partly a very great range of people
not particularly poets or professors of
poetry Robert let's talk a little bit
about about the the the Democratic
implications of this I mean clearly one
of the implications of the whole project
is to say poetry should be
we shouldn't think of poetry as a kind
of a lead activity which only professors
and poet tasters like but that it's
something that that ordinary people can
enjoy and and experience the poetry
belongs to everyone but of course there
are plenty of poets who think that this
is sort of selling out we can sort of
differently we could say we're
establishing a true a lead of people who
understand a poem have incorporated can
read it aloud in a way that other people
can perceive it against the false elite
of people who get tenure at Yale or
Harvard or be you or somewhere and often
don't know anything about what a poem
actually is so it's a it's a the elitism
is the elitism of people who are
actually responding to a poem in a way
that can be communicated to another
person which is very fundamental the art
of poetry and it substitutes for a
couple of elites there's the academic
elite which sometimes really not very
close to the nature of the art of poetry
and in our country what the most true
elite in American culture is an elite
based on performers so that instead of
kings and queens and Dukes and Earls and
Duchess's we have singers and actors and
athletes this is a great improvement
far better to idealize somebody because
they can throw a ball like hell or
they're beautiful they can sing and
dance very well then because of who
their great great grandparents were but
this is different from either the
academic world or the media world of
celebrity this is an art in which each
individual's the readers body the
readers breath is the medium Walt
Whitman is dead John Dougherty is alive
John Dougherty's breath saying those
words by whitman become Whitman's media
it's not Whitman being read by an actor
it's not written in himself giving a
terrific poetry reading on the poetry
reading circuit it is the readers
realization literal realization of the
poem and yes I think that in a democracy
the idea of an art in which not the
performer but each into an art that is
inherently on a human scale on the scale
of one person I love digital media this
is a digital medium itself but the
medium that is also human and bottling
as in this subject of the Opera there's
a certain respect for that and I think
there are ways you could argue that in a
democracy this ancient art in some brace
has non-democratic origins courtly
origins has an important function
because it inherently respects what used
to be called the dignity of the
individual do you remember the JV
cunningham poem the talks of them
breathes on the words he made sort of an
embodiment of your I couldn't quote it
but yes it was a test you were supposed
to be able to quote the artist is dead
but the readers breath literal or
imaginary because it might not be
reading aloud it might be just hearing
it in your mind's here that is your
particular vendor
formal possession by the date if John
Dougherty reads that or I David reads
the Connie hammer i read a Ben Johnson
that sliver of that original
consciousness is being realized in the
new person's breath but it can it also
be realized why we're just reading why
do I have to read it aloud to reanimate
it poetry is an art that takes for its
material sounds of a language and if
your is rep and said poetry is a centaur
by which he means in prose you fire an
arrow at a target in poetry you do the
same thing but you're writing a horse at
the same time and the horse I take to be
the human body the bodily part of poetry
so if you're reading a poem and not
hearing it at all as far as I'm
concerned you're missing an important
part of it also true if you're stupid
you won't get it all it is an art of the
mind and of the body and every art that
i can think of in some way uses
something physical music uses physical
sounds film is a physical phenomenon you
take it visually and aurally you know or
plastic art visual arts and poetry also
has a physical bodily component and that
is the sounds of the words let's show
you one more fragment from this and then
we'll go on to some other discussion we
can come back to these but right do you
could I nominate one but I think she
actually starts reading right away and
I'd rather just either he could we do
number four and I think I think she
actually reads the poem in the precise
league in enen are I think so let's just
look at the recitation in the beginning
and not watch the whole unless you think
it's valuable I thought we would I don't
want to watch only part of one of them I
want to watch the whole summer all right
all right it's your it's your project
I'll go through with this with this
tedious idea go ahead actually it's a
very this is my favorite of all of the
of all of them in moving slow he has no
peer you ask him something but Beatrice
about it for a year I interrupted her
the sly I fear directive in moving slow
he has no peer you ask him something in
his ear he thinks about it for a year
and then before he says a word they're
upside down unlike a bird he will assume
that you have heard a most exasperating
lug but should you call his manner smug
he'll sigh and give his French a hug
then off again to sleep he goes still
swaying gently by his toes and you just
know he knows he knows and 11 years old
I live in Lexington Massachusetts she's
actually very charming and at the end of
this fragment she reads it again she
recites it again even more remarkably
she analyzes the said I'd rather hear
Robert than his than his rope she says
that she likes the line still swaying
gently by his toes he says quite
correctly that's an amount of poetic
just used that word which says it's like
you can see him swinging there I don't
mean to deprecate the entire academic
profession of the study of literature
but it is true that often you will hear
an extremely celebrated grun profesor or
profesora give a lecture and when the
person reads parts of the palms you
realize the person is not hearing the
palms this is not incidental or
ornamental and it's not histrionics
skill it's not being an actor these are
not trained actors but it's a little bit
like music or dancing you're either
doing it or not and you can tell when
some it just is not not hearing it and
so I say that partly missed
obviously part need to say that it's not
all about democracy or the people there
also is something exacting about art and
every art has its techniques and its
demands and it can be quite stringent
and it's not just that isn't it cute
that a child or construction workers
reading a poem the things they say about
the palms in every case I think are
cogent the the book Prince 200 palms and
there's a quotation from a letter that I
got next to each palm we try to choose
things that were quite illuminating so
there's an aspect of the project i'm
happy to say is a latest as well as
clearly an aspect that is democratic to
I was the editor I chose which letters I
thought were very good and though the
poems included don't represent my tastes
exactly there aren't the poems I would
have chosen did you represent my
standards if a poem was not up to my
standards we didn't put in an anthology
we didn't make a video of it Casey at
the bat Casey at the bat perhaps an
exception but it's a very good piece of
pop art and the kid does do it very well
well I'm glad you're in favor of some
aspects of pop art I'd like make a quick
transition we don't have a lot of time
and I want to give the audience a chance
at you but there are at least two topics
that I want us to talk a little bit
about Robert one of them is what has
always struck me as one of the most
remarkable and interesting things about
your career I a brief background when
Robert first began to publish he was
immensely influential as a even as a
young poet because he seemed to be doing
something at the time that was new in
quotes in the sense that the established
line in poetry was elsewhere and what
was new essentially was how deeply
conversational his early poetry was in
his first few books of poetry not only
had a kind of conversational feel but
they were but they were and and and a
kind of syntactic coherence that was
close in some respects closer to prose
than it was to poetry although they were
very sort of thought through and
full poems they were true poems there
was this not exactly prosaic but
conversational dimension to Robert's
early poetry and especially in the in
the book entitled an explanation of
America as as as as you've gone on
though your poetry has changed in
somewhat radical ways and in somewhat
surprising ways and there have been some
essays written about this which I've
learned from studying Roberts working at
different stages of his career but to
oversimplify his his work becomes less
and less conversational it becomes
harder i think more difficult sometimes
harder to follow you have to work harder
to get the meeting although i think he's
always an accessible power and moves
toward a condition in which writing
something closer to incantation than
conversation and there's a deeply sort
of encanta Tory and visionary dimension
to his most recent poetry many people
have many people have commented on this
well my first question is do you
remember a moment in your own work when
you felt a turning like that I mean I
know of some homes i might nominate but
i was wondering if you felt a moment
where you was changing it's so hard to
write a good poem and you die not
knowing if you ever have i mean if you
want to know that you've done something
right you must become something like a
surgeon or an airline pilot really
seriously then you know you know you you
flew your you perform the mission to do
with the surgery or the you know you you
have a much more objective measure than
if you're an artist earlier to the
students earlier i quoted he keeps his
epic path that he wrote for himself here
lies one whose name was written water
part of him knew or suspected that he
was john keats that people like us would
be reading his words hundreds of years
later but since he wasn't a madman he
also admitted the possibility perhaps
his life had been in vain he had not
written masterpieces and when he thought
he did dura delusion and
being a genius he wrote a brilliant
epitaph that covers both cases it's
ironic if he is John Keats and it is a
very moving evocation of what it is to
have your name be written water if not
it's so hard to write a good poem that
when you are trying to do it what you
were thinking about is how you can
possibly approach that goal so you're
not thinking about well I've done the
conversational thing I think time to be
a little more incantation aren't gonna
be your you're much more you're much
more like something that's exactly how I
thought it would trying to keep trying
to keep an airplane in the air or trying
to save the patient you know you're just
desperately you know very intensely
trying to make something that works it's
also true that explanation of America is
spoken to it it's and it's spoken
fictionally to a child between the ages
of eight and eleven and almost because
of that it's a book-length poem with a
little preparatory poem that is rather
imagistic and is more incantation ille
and apone at the end that is also much
less conversational and more like a
linear prayer I wasn't consciously
saying look I can do that too but it
seemed an appropriate way to say this is
a little bit like I'm writing a concerto
minor keys are involved another time I
might be writing a song cycle or this
isn't a major key that there is not only
development there's also different tasks
at some point it is true I fell in love
with the substantive and this is I mean
grammatically and this is like talking
about nuts and bolts I had been very
much in love with very complicated
sentences like the first sentence of
George Herbert spawn Church monuments
the man is about to go to pray and he
stops in the graveyard outside the
church and he addresses his body and he
says the souls can go and pray now body
little child you'd be good stay out here
and look at this you learn something
from it while that my soul repairs to
her devotion here I into my flesh that
it
times may take acquaintance of these
heaps of dust to which the blasts of
deaths incessant motion fed by the
exhalation of our crimes drives all at
last you know your diagram and on the
blackboard it's like a spidery thing but
how beautiful the energy is directed
while that my soul repairs her devotion
here I until my flesh that it be times
may take acquaintance of these heaps of
dust to which the blast of deaths
incessant motion fed by the exhalation
of our crimes drives all at last I once
asked a lot of doctoral students at
Berkeley what's the main verb of that
sentence some of them said drives no f
it is in to integrate everything grows
off and tomb the problem is called
Church monuments so part of oneself
technically is in love with the idea of
how much energy syntax generate and it's
taking the rhymes as it goes and it's
taking the line endings as it goes and
then at some point you've been doing
that a lot those long sentences at some
point you know you're probably thinking
about shirt where the Suttons is coming
with the articles the yoke the back the
needle the treadle this is this hand one
of Roberts most famous poems it's a
prize-winning poem called shirt maybe
you should read it Robert maybe but why
don't you meet in the door poems a
question but describe it and then read
it substance mean that poem in fact goes
all over the lot intellectually but
things I've read the I plagiarize a
little bit of a thing here and have
another idea I got from there but the
poem is sort of dominated by that the
sense of substances in that case with
the article this this the that there's
an there's a power to that it's a kind
of individuals fragment since he doesn't
want to read it it's a kind of inventory
I'll read it but he would be much more
cooperative it wasn't his friend it's
what friends are for it's so nice oh no
I mustn't know
you know I thought he's not behaving
well if he doesn't behave better i'm
going to recite some of his suppressed
poetry that I said to challenge I said
to David Koepp enticing tell me a good
read sure an applicant I don't want to
begging me to do it shirt the back the
yoke the yardage lacked seems the nearly
invisible stitches along the collar
turned in a sweatshop by Koreans or
Malaysians gossiping over tea and
noodles on their break or talking money
or politics while one fitted this arm
piece with its overseen to the band of
cuff I button at my wrist the presser
the cutter the ringer the mangle the
needle the Union the treadle the bobbin
the code the infamous blaze at the
triangle Factory in 1911 146 died in the
flames on the ninth floor no hydrants no
fire escapes the witness in the building
across the street who watched how a
young man helped a girl to step up to
the window sill then held her out away
from the masonry wall and let her drop
and then another as if he were helping
them up to enter a streetcar and not
eternity a third before he dropped her
put her arms around his neck and kissed
him then he held her into space and
dropped her almost at once he stepped to
the sill himself his jacket flared and
fluttered up from his shirt as he came
down air filling up the legs of his grey
trousers leichhardt cranes bedlamite
shrill shirt ballooning wonderful how
the pattern matches perfectly across the
placket and over the twin bart act
corners of both pockets like a strict
rhyme or a major chord prints plaids
checks houndstooth Patterson Madras the
clan tartans invented by mill owners
inspired by the hoax of ocean to control
their savage Scottish workers tamed by a
fabricated heraldry MacGregor Bailey
McMartin the kilt devised for workers to
wear among the dusty clattering looms
weavers Carter's spinners the loader the
doctor the na'vi the planter the picker
the sorter sweating at her machine in a
litter of cotton as slaves in calico
head rags sweated in fields George
Herbert your descendant is a black lady
in South Carolina her name is Irma and
she inspected my shirt its color and fit
and feel and it's clean smell have
satisfied both her and me we have called
its cost and quality down to the buttons
of simulated bone the buttonholes the
sizing the facing the characters printed
in black on neck band and tail the shape
the label the labor the color the shade
the shirt thank you Robert the later
palms become even more visionary and we
may have a chance to look at those of
later but I want to make a transition to
the final topic we'll discuss before we
open to the to general discussion and
that is this recent prose book that
Robert has written called the life of
David I've read it closely and been
deeply moved by it and it strikes me
that one of the interesting things about
the book it is like a vast Pinsky poem
that is to say it's full of disparate
energies that seem to sort of create at
least a the illusion of an absence of
coherence but when you finally when you
finish the whole you realize how richly
coherent it is and it is in some degree
a kind of departure for a poet like
Robert Pinsky to turn to this sort of a
book it's a I thought that first Robert
I might ask you to sort of in a just a
general way describe how you why you
felt that David was such a fascinating
figure what why he mattered to you in a
way I'll try to unite the two subjects
the previous subject in this one syntax
and poetry is the equivalent of melody
in music it connects things over time
it's the equivalent perhaps of harmonic
structure but even more of melody so
that any good syntax is in some sense
conversational that it converts and it's
between so that sometimes when people
are talking they talk and rather like
wow that my soul repairs the devotion
here my stoma fuscous hypnotized it and
there are other times when it is more
also conversation when it's no hydrants
no fire escapes Yates says in a letter
it is the syntax of in memoriam that is
odious it is the language of no man when
moved our teacher winter says somewhere
else about poetry doesn't like something
one would never say moving in a certain
way on some level it has to seem like
some even if the person were muttering
it to themselves it's what connects part
two part and to say no hydrants no fire
escapes is to emphasize minimal
connection
and to say wow that my soul repairs
those here item if that connect suggests
very very almost in cracking elaborate
hypo tactic and pirate tactic syntax are
the rhetorical terms the David book is
in a way about being Jewish it's about
what is a Jew and Jews through and
historical destiny are highly syncretic
you might even say synthetic sense of
synthesis and connecting one thing to
another thing yeah it's been said one of
the things people say about juices if
you go to chill a or you could go to
Romania or if you go to Alabama and
Obama the most Chilean chili a nose are
the Jews that they are extremely
adaptable in some sense so that in this
country Irving Berlin who was born in
Russia and had a longer name than Berlin
at one point wrote white Christmas and
having succeeded at that he also wrote
Easter Parade David for interesting
reasons we can speculate about rather
than Abraham is the quintessential hero
of these people may brahim is the father
he's the first joke David his some of
the rabbi's say is he really Jewish she
said among the Jews his
great-grandmother was Ruth a Moabite
woman my chapter about Goliath is titled
to cousin Goliath I point out with the
light in the last chapter that the
six-pointed star is of David only by the
most imaginative process he never if
there was an actual person there it
wasn't until really what they now call
early modern Europe wasn't there like 14
15th century that that symbol of six
pointed star was connected with Jews
it's a great symbol the two triangles
the male dagger pointing to the sky
embraces the earth the females chalice
open to the sky points to the earth
so it's a yin-yang symbol and David to
is all of the above he's a great killer
he's a great poet he's an artist he's a
politician he's a terrible person he's a
great person he has this he connects
many things he's very disparate and just
as one is interested technically in all
the many many ways that one word is
connected to another word all the
varieties of syntaxin know to
grammatical junctures are exactly the
same even if you write a line like
tomorrow and tomorrow and tomorrow and
tomorrow each and in each tomorrow has a
slightly different character each
juncture is a slightly different
juncture because the pressure of
repetition varies through the course of
the line and just as one might be
fascinated by all the infinite range of
grammatical junctures and connections
one is interested in the yin and yang
the inclusive did I do that dagger
chalice thing right female chalice
points this earth the male dagger points
to the sky yeah I'm okay yes you were
right now um it is all of the above the
colony of David to be all of the above
the poly the Jews to be all the above
are related in my line mind to the
ambition of writing a kind of poetry in
which anything can be included well the
the David book it is perhaps less
capacious than some of the poems because
not everything is included it relevant
but it is a kind of very imaginative
retelling of the David story that goes
beyond the Bible in some respects I
thought maybe you should you might
mention something about some of the
other homework you did when you were
working on the book it was so easy to do
the homework because Louis Ginsburg
compiled this great great compilation
called the legends of the Jews it's all
the crazy weird Midrash is all of the
stories and he ranges it by character so
there are things about David or right
there and they are
and they are very very weird the one
that I'll tell them quickly the one that
epitomizes what I just said about
inclusiveness David was not supposed to
live his full 70 years as he did his
original destiny mr. died as an infant
but Adam happened to be walking around
in the part of heaven where the souls
are waiting to be born he saw David sony
said wow that's a great soul back that
kid has been hey thats all should die oh
he should have a whole life fortunately
god it's in that part of heaven too and
david and they're going to be born and
adam says to God that that kid should
have a hole he's that's a great salt you
you gave me a thousand years to live
I'll give him 70 in my years so God
calls up lawyer angels the write up a
contract the undersigned Adam does
hereby believer the year of sudden and
David gets Laveau well this is Adam
who's the seed all the potential good
and bad and glorious and various things
that we can do easy he's the seed of all
of us and he recognizes the soul that is
all of the above so he's all the above
and sin potential he recognizes the life
that has come closest to the fruition or
flowering of everything that a person
might be and that's not biblical that
some manic rabbi made that up it's it
it's sir it's certainly it's it's it's
certainly a book that will surprise you
even if you have no interest in the
Bible or in David you'll find this a
remarkable book and there's a turning at
the end that I think we could conclude
on I'd like to ask you Robert to read
the very end of the book because you
have a copy if you need it there there
is a very little hint of an
autobiographical dimension to the book
and unlike many of Roberts poems which
always have at least a kind of hint of a
of a personal engagement but the
autobiographical element emerges with a
star
machine clarity and mu and poignant at
the very end of the book and that's the
part of the book that I'm asking Robert
to look here okay David is more
enigmatic than any purely Christian or
Jewish paradigm more tangled at the
roots and more proliferating larger an
enduring story of stories necessarily
involves quirks and guises a paradoxical
in crustacean of Midrash for example the
six-pointed figure known as the Star of
David was pretty certainly unknown to
David though Gregory Peck where's the
image on his tunic in david and
bathsheba the six-pointed star was not
associated with King David nor with Jews
until more than a thousand years after
the time of David the star is of David
the Psalms are of David the very stories
in the Hebrew Bible and in the legends
are of David or of him by sovereign
possessive force of attribution beyond
scholarly demonstration in there are
different ways and degrees all rotating
around David's genitive central energy
that attracts and embraces them in the
Roman Forum on the triumphal arch of the
emperor Titus celebrating his capture
and destruction of Jerusalem a
millennium after its founding the
branched candelabrum appears but not the
anachronistic star is not mentioned in
the Bible norm the Talmud nor in the
rabbinical literature the first Jewish
source to mention the stars in the 13th
century of the Common Era symbol doesn't
appear to be much used before the 15th
century the Jewish encyclopedia says it
probably was the Kabbalah that deprived
the symbol from the Templars i'll skip
the paragraph I've already paraphrased
to you about the male dagger and the
female chalice the star of David's
history has been far from uniformly
sweet when the Portuguese monarch Afonso
for reserved it reversed his
predecessors benign policies all Jews
were forbidden to appear in public
without a visible six-pointed yellow
star on their hat or coat in this regard
the Nazis again appear as not originate
errs but copiers adapters exploiters and
refiners
continuing and extending the theme of
inclusion Gershom Scholem and his essay
on the star commends the wisdom of
converting the symbol of oppression into
an insignia of national identity on the
flag of Israel and as a glyph
unmistakable as the cross the stringent
geometry of the star in the way of human
makings accepts but transfigures its
range of meanings here is a particular
instance a photograph of 12 young men
taken in the bad year 1939 so not to
their uniforms is that six pointed star
of interlocked triangles said to be
borrowed from a device of the Knights
Templar and incorporated without
rabbinic approval into the agonized
mysticism xand paedon trees of Kabbalah
the young men squinting back at the
camera are named Ralph bender Joseph
Siegel Nathan Schneider Morris Newberg
Herman Schneider go Burt Kaplan Harry
silver David Becker Milton silver
Milford Penske Abraham bomb and Seymour
barren they are the Jewish aces in
shorts kneepads and basketball shoes one
of them holds a basketball on which
someone has painted city champs 1938
1939 another cradles the trophy with its
crowning figure of an athlete holding
the ball overhead in the trophy makers
stylized gesture of attainment in plated
metal they are standing in front of
their high school in Long Branch New
Jersey 1939 the group picture is an
interesting artifact because of the
apparent wacky or tragic incongruity of
that six-pointed emblem deployed in
Europe for such different purposes far
more like those of King Afonso at the
moment the photograph was taken the
players of the Jewish cases were most
likely far from unaware of the laws and
measures enacted by the third ray
some of them would eventually go into
battle against that regime it seems safe
to assume also that on that Sunday
afternoon in Long Branch beaming at the
camera the young men were aware of the
assertive maybe even defiant quality of
the team's name the Jewish aces the
implications of aces superior raffish
primary sensual worldly singular or loan
victorious adept also fit David in such
impure fluid partly accidental
manifestations certain human doings
continued as nodes of energy durably
complex particles that really shift and
recombine to exceed likelihood and eve a
prediction King David like the
six-pointed design he would not have
recognized gathers meaning in assisted
Lee and D Astley of need and invention
over centuries of attainment and outrage
suffering an ordinary life in an
endlessly glamorous stubborn a crucial
thank you Robert a floor is open to
questions comments responses of various
kinds yes can you come to the microphone
because we're the event is being
recorded and we want to hear what
everyone has to say I can repeat
questions too if others don't try to do
that that the answer to my question is
already contained in some of your
remarks but um I wanted to know if you
could comment on the importance of the
human voice as the medium of poetry when
you first launched the favorite poem
project i started to thinking about what
my face
Ricola might be and all of the poems
that originally came to my mind were
poems that I had memorized as a child
now did i memorize them because they
were my favorites or did they become my
favorites because I memorized them i
don't know but you were talking about
you know the voice as being kind of an
an embodiment or maybe a reimburse pirit
to mine say or spirits a good word
because it means breath in Latin okay ah
say the Whitman poem and you know
especially at a moment in history where
we're shifting our media and you know
technology you know poetry was
originally spoken I believe and I just
wanted to know if you could talk about
voice and poetry the human voice the
spoken voice an important distinction
for me is that it is a vocal art though
not necessarily a performative art and
in a culture where as I've said
performance is so central it's a very
important distinction when you memorize
those poems you incorporated them it
took them into your body quite literally
you know isn't that of the redbury novel
where certain people have memorized
certain poems that person's body is that
book the poem in my opinion is something
that happens it takes place each time
someone reads it it is like a piece of
music it happens each time it's been
there's notation that represents it but
it is something that happens in the
course of a certain amount of time it
takes place it takes place in a literal
or imagined voice so the vocality is not
an ornament it is not part of a show
business as a category of show business
poetry always be kind of cute and
trivial as an art its immense and
central
its nature is vocal its intellectual as
well as in the pound metaphor of the
center but it is also essentially vocal
and I really do I suppose I'm promoting
my product but the DVD you've only
gotten a glimpse of it the DVD that is
in that book invitation to poetry is for
me I can't tell you how glad I am that
teachers can get it to me it's a great
teaching tool the teacher can show the
kids not a tape of a professor talking
about the palm or sir john deere good
reading Shakespeare or of an act a rap
artist doing a skillful or the poet with
a great personality it's anyone at all
who loves the poem and that to me is
very important in the nature of the art
I encourage you to sort of meditate your
questions raise your hands when you're
ready while we're waiting for more
energy from the audience I have a
question you mentioned Eve or winters a
little while ago Robert and he was
certainly the most compelling teacher I
ever experienced and Robert and I we're
at Stanford together in a period when
this astonishing poet critic was very
important influence on anyone who came
within a hundred miles of Stanford I
wonder if you talk a little bit about
winters and how you see him now from the
in many ways your your career is not
congenial to what winters might have
imagined for you I think it's
necessarily true I remember one time
that another teacher we had bowed
Pfeiffer wonderful manner throughout the
18th century described reading
applications with winters and bud
Pfeiffer said I i thought i was going to
please him his intellectual side and i
said look at this woman she says the
main part of poetry for her is the
sounds of the words and winter said
looks pretty much right
I bid 500 I guess I kiss it and what I
remember very well as winters really
particularly in French very beautiful he
had a rather beautiful voice he said
about his own work and poetry what I did
was small but good and he broke
beautiful little pond this is upon by
overwinters a summer commentary when I
was young with sharper sense the
farthest insect cry i heard could stay
me through the trees intense i watched
the hunter and the bird where is the
meaning that i found or was it but a
state of mind some old penumbra of the
ground ground in which to be but not
defined now summer grasses brown with
heat have crowded sweetness through the
air the very roadside dust is sweet even
the unshared earth is fair the soft
voice of the nesting dove and the Dove
and Swift erratic flight like a rapid
hand within a glove caress the silence
and the light beautiful last answer amid
the rubble the Fallen fruit fermenting
in its rich DK smears brandy under
trampling boot and sends its sweeter on
its way amid the rubble befallen fruit
fermenting and its rich 2k smears brandy
on the trampoline and sends it sweeter
on its way that sense of scale it's a
very beautiful and David and I were
fortunate to study with a real artist
who's also very learning man I think his
work lives I think people still other
celebrity critics of the time seemed to
me absolutely for God and Ivan only I
remember there was someone named plant
Brooks whereas I think winters people
are still quoting him in arguing with
him and he did leave write those poems
that are terrific not great great poet
his emphasis was very powerfully
rationalist his great collection of
critical writings was called in defense
of reason and he was often complained
against for emphasizing the rationale so
intensely that the emotional dimension
of poetry was given according to these
complaints the inadequate
acknowledgement in winters account I
take it you don't agree Robert he was
very irritated by some of his I surance
remember he had been the one who asked
him of what he made it affect so many
nuns came to study with him it took his
courses and he did look very cute what
in the world they think I'm saying um he
was now he had his blindness a--'s but
he did not just say the poems were only
rational no he was very interested in
the interplay between things I've been
talking to you about he had his
limitations I'm proud to say that David
and I were not amongst the robots we
were willing to arguing with him that
there was a lot to be said in behalf of
Yates as compared to discourage more
right while others were just saying yeah
okay ste thirds more greater one of the
things Robert and I did when we were in
graduate school Wheatley Winters was
famous for making obiter dicta judgments
of poets he disliked so he would say
things like Wordsworth is a minimum is a
marginal figure and he would often he
would often choose you know iconic
figured he would say Shakespeare's
sonnets are not what they're cracked up
to be say they would say things like
that and he would and he would also also
celebrate or or or argue for poets no
one had ever heard of often with
ridiculous names from very comical names
like Barnaby guj and Adelaide Crapsey
was another one of the poets that
winter's went just defended and at one
point because we were sort of arrogant
graduate students Robert and I
collaborated on a parody of winters in
which i wrote the pros and robert wrote
all the poetry and it was a it was a
sort of fake winters essay in which
we in which we created in which we
created a typical winters poet who was
virtually unknown I think what is it
well you looked at Jones very that's
thrown this very was one of the colonial
discoveries and actually Jones very
interesting bones so one more one of
winters Phaedra nazario injury early
18th century American poet named I've
learned since it's actually pronounced
Jonas berry but it's Jones very if you
see it spell and Jones very was one of
winters is great discoveries and amongst
other he had couplets at the bottom of
the page and his palms and one of the
couples was I now I'll read it in the
winters voice I know repose my weary
head upon my pillow but I shall be
shortly gone not bad a little gloomy and
our poet was called Smith extremely and
and Robert wrote a series of comical
little poems i wish i had the text here
the paraphrase the rational paraphrase
of all the poems one was a sauna
eligible in all forms and all of them
basically said I put a seedless roll
into my lunch box i wish i could find
this manuscript i think it would be
worth something now because of Roberts
be the only one we remember is the
couplet I now insert a seedless roll
into my lunch box but I shall be shortly
through
so I remember reading this to another
colleague of a professor that we both
liked very much a great a great man in
his own right who had been a student of
winters himself Albert Gerard and Gerard
loved this parody but he warned us never
to let winter see it and to my knowledge
he never saw it we were so scared that
all all copy there no extant copies
unless you've been Hardwell I have one
but I can't find it I question okay then
you'll be second in english language
Voyager there is no big time whatsoever
anymore you are suffering the question
is why in this day in the age in the
English language is there no rhyme and
anymore you're not the only person to
have that misapprehension i think that
joseph brodsky who wrote so many awful
poems in english also had that notion
that he was the only one writing in
rhyme and meter many people do some very
well phangan wrote grapples wonderful
poems a beautiful elegy for his brother
in palm inviting as his brother suburb
tom wrote dutifully in couplets he is
only one example so it's not the case
you know I David's been talking about an
explanation for America I broke my neck
writing that poem in iambic pentameter
and the shirt palm that are read to you
shirt is also in the measure of iambic
pentameter and rhyme in English was not
was considered vulgar by writers like
Milton because the classical languages
didn't rhyme so it's a more complicated
question than it appears to be and the
fact that there are a lot of people who
writing free verse badly not really
verse at all shouldn't obscure the fact
it's possible to write rhyme and meter
quite badly too I'm afraid
it all depends yes sir as a practitioner
of maybe the most humanistic of the arts
of poetry you've just finished an opera
about a man who wants to be a robot and
it's introduced by robots does that
horrify you the idea that someone would
wish to be a machine do you think that
the robots will ever be able to write
poetry the same way that humans would
the character in the characters mind
he's doing the opposite of becoming a
machine he's free himself from the
fungible mortal machine of the body he's
leaving matter he thinks he's becoming
pure spirit and the word robot as I
understand it as a czech word original
it means worker thing that works in that
sense we all aspire to be robots we all
go to get our work done this is one of
the great human pleasures I don't think
it's that simple I do want very much
with that story to raise questions like
the questions you're asking whether I
mean there are characters I'd make a
joke of it in the Opera but they're also
says there are characters three
characters named the United Nations the
United Way and the administration come
to Simon and say what about the starving
of the earth what about people who are
suffering you've already upset the world
economy by putting all your resources
into this project and in the script it
does say there is a pageant a parade of
the starving and suffering of the earth
people who don't have enough to eat or
water people have terrible diseases
children and there's we somehow put that
on stage I don't know how we put it on
stage it's more almost more of a social
question as a philosophical one in the
Opera I'm not unaware of the question
but I wouldn't boil it down to he oh he
wants to become a robot I didn't I was
very interested their idea of robotics
very interested by the idea of being of
thinking machines and of this idea that
we are evolving away from the human
container for Intel that intelligence
itself will evolve into some other
format let's say
uh I didn't want to make a trite
Frankenstein story out of it I didn't
want to say yet again Oh your
overweening will come to a bad end I
wanted to make it more ambiguous than
that and the daughter character has a
very she's very ambivalent about this
and she has a strong social conscience
and many misgivings and all through
including the bit your hair here it
quotes quotes that wonderful may Swenson
poem body my horse my hand what will I
do who will I be and she says well how
will I remember without my forgetting
how I live without my debts and I think
those are important questions but I
don't want to answer them in a way that
is merely humanistic in some facile way
so it's it's it's it's smoky down yes
sir we have in the frontier two things
by way of introduction to my question I
want to cover what you just said from my
limited knowledge robot is a czech word
that was popularized if not invented by
karel capek and how you are anyway
that's beside the point the question I
had you kind of threw me off David I
don't know your last name professor this
is David O'Byrne I'm sorry okay you said
that dr. pants keys David was the point
of departure for him I think those are
your words as though he was creating
something new for himself I take mild
exception and I could be wrong I think
you may be right because I mean would
agree with you and dr. Pinsky's poem
about a longish poem about Daniel okay I
see a lot of biblical adherence and yet
a certain personal creativity of his own
building on what the Bible offers about
Daniel and you know giving it a lot more
a lot more cloth and also in something
as disparate
a precursor from that is his poem about
the Child Jesus and so I if you have
those two getting eggs together if you
will I think they both form a precursor
to the current David completely from the
childhood of Jesus is a model for the
David book and it's based on the infancy
Gospel of Thomas in other other parts of
the apocryphal Book of Thomas and the
idea of Apocrypha the idea of Midrash
those are very interesting ideas to me
it seems to me that retellings read
actions improvisations at what point is
the star get attached what point of the
songs get attached to him in what way
Jesus and East tellings becomes rather a
brat unlike in the Christian scriptures
we see him between infancy and
adolescents and he's a very difficult
child who only joseph has authority over
him this human quality of retelling of
giving another version seems to me one
of the many points of nexus between art
and human behavior art is not its
artists continuous with things that
people do all day we make little mini
works of art famously in our dreams but
when you're trying to be amusing to
someone in a phone conversation or when
friends try to have fun at a party when
you choose colors for your living room
or when you we do our grooming adore
little works of art and a a character
like Daniel or Jesus or David the
biblical part is only a part of all the
tremendous and crustacean of human
thought and feeling that it's built
around that thing and it's deeply human
and I'm endlessly interested in that
phenomena and yeah I think of my book
about David is being a stone that I add
to this huge human monument all the
things that people the movies that
Midrash is the calm
tyrese the attacks did the bizarre
exculpation people invented for the
terrible things he does as to Uriah the
Hittite so certain number of scholars
makeup absolutely bizarre stories and
theories to you know you ride the hip
height looks like a straight hour a nice
guy in the Bob aurelia he had the key to
Goliath armor and Goliath was covered
the trolley David couldn't cut his head
off goes to the armor so Uriah said well
I have the key but I'll give you the key
if you give me a beautiful Israelite
bride so he wasn't entitled to bed Sheba
anyway it's hard to believe that some of
these sages were not did not have any
access to marijuana that is all part of
the process of becoming and telling
again and bringing out the nefarious and
sinister aspects of the story a stories
as great as these read us Jesus reads us
David reads us each telling reads
whoever reads it that's what I mean by a
story of stories and I'm very interested
in that process with the book reads you
then you read the book back and forth
endlessly way back say it's 2070 will if
the Republic survives will the poet
laureate be propped up by structure or
by subject it's 2070 by structure you're
talking about aesthetic structure I'm
talking about some social structure
exactly i'm talking about the structure
the format of one's the structure of
one's work for me it will begin with the
human body is there is is there a way
that someone will want to say again the
words another person made i chose to say
you words that winters put together i
chose this afternoon to put words say
words that frank O'Hara and a Thomas
Nash put together the 20
and in the 16th century my strongest
ambition is that a hundred years from
now some woman who study English in
Tanzania or Ogando or believes or pile
and will choose to say words that i put
together and in 2070 I think poet
laureate is not important it's just a
sort of a it's a title but if there is a
poet who as I have gotten inspiration
from frank O'Hara Emily Dickinson Ivor
winters whatever the things are I've
read I'm hoping that it's the center I'm
hoping that boat that the person looks
around has feelings and says I'm going
to I'm going to express these feelings
by the sounds of the words and if I'm
one of the models that's much more
important than poet laureate use the
microphone to be I'll repeat what she
says all right writing a poem but it's
also true that not all poets feel that
that some poets have found it easy you
have to write or at least there are
periods when people have a tremendous
and flowing of work so I was wondering
do you feel that hardness first of all
have you ever had a period that was like
that and do you feel that that hardness
has to do with you personally with the
kind of work that you're trying to make
or what the question has to do with my
saying that it's how so hard to write a
good poem and the questioner rightly
points out that some poets that found it
easy or the times in a career when
people find it easy frank O'Hara said I
like to play the typewriter after
breakfast for an hour
um it's like this you have to climb a
mountain find your way through a maze
get to the field that has a tree in it
you climb up to the top of the tree and
you wait for a thunderstorm then it's
easy once you're hit by lightning it's a
computer game to get hit by lightning to
get hit by lightning once you're hit by
lightning no problem I'm hit by
lightning but you go through a lot of
school through before you can get there
and you know you listen to listen to
that famous thing where Illinois Jacquet
played flying home at the newport jazz
festival and it sounds like it sounds so
exciting and it also sounds like he just
he's breathing he's having sex he's
eating he's just doing something you
know no problem he had to learn to play
this major minor scales and all keys he
you know you don't pick up a saxophone
and just blow it he studied he
understands the harmonic structure that
rather simple blues like harmonic
structure chord chord progression a lot
goes you work real hard to get to where
it's easy what Robert in a related
aspect to that question that struck me
as you were talking the comment that you
made one Robert was commissioned to
write a poem about nine eleven by The
Washington Post it's a beautiful poem
and it was reprinted in one the best
American poems of whatever year it was
and they poets are asked to make a
comment in it and Roberts comment was
interesting because he says Pete because
this was an assignment people think this
was hard then you say not really if to
talk about that you know people are
surprised by this got me on some
occasions it's fun to say that it's very
hard to write a good Paul on some
occasions it's fun to say it's not hard
I i used to say people would talk about
translating the inferno and
would say translation is it's easy
because it's impossible if you try and
do something impossible it's a
light-hearted enterprise because you
know there's no such thing an assignment
people so it must be difficult to write
to assignment in a way an assignment
gives you the freedom of saying got to
do this and there's something a little
bit liberating it's like I use the same
word where that i often find a cat word
word in the brain i use them when i
talked about working with todd one of
the human beings enjoyed difficulty very
much and when you're doing the video
game or playing golf or basketball or
tennis or you're working on a new
knitting pattern or building a boat
software you're figuring out or solving
a problem at work you get to a point
where it's neither difficult nor easy
it's just what you want to be doing and
it's hard to remember to eat or go to
the bathroom because you just want to be
doing that and I think that is one of
the most desired human states and that
engaging a worthy difficulty difficulty
worthy of yourself and I said that about
that poem and in recent weeks in
correspondence with somebody who wrote
an essay about the palm I've been
revising it ever since I think I may
finally have it right at one point I
took it out of my book because frankly I
felt that you know the I have to find
out which polish boated is Adam Zucker
yes key quoted as saying during the
Soviet years most ambitious poet was the
state they wanted to control all the
metaphors and i felt that i felt quite
frankly I ain't I feel like going to be
preaching to the choir something I don't
want this to be a big but I felt that
the Bush administration had so much
taken over 911 that my poem had changed
and that I was unhappy I was not happy
to think that
that the meaning of my palm is going to
somehow accede to the use of this as a
really preposterous political slogan
like invading a country that had nothing
to do with him over fighting back back
he's respected people here that it I I
have gone through agony over that bomb
which I you remind me I said in print it
was easier to write I've never spent so
long revising a poem and frankly the
woman what the woman said about it
describe just the poem i want to have
written it included the ambiguity and
she she felt i was going crazy which
could be true i have revised the poem I
provides the constant look the post
version is different from the best
american poetry version the version
that's been in my manuscript that it
took out bad in his different sheet this
woman who wrote this beautiful essay
about my poem i emailed her the latest
revision which incorporates a lot of
katherine lee bates 'as america the
beautiful near the end I haven't heard
from her i think she thinks i screwed my
Bobo she [ __ ] she's been very afraid
of me says oh I don't know if she may be
right or fight of her she may be right
she may be right one of the really
remarkable things about Robert I mean
many things about him I admire but he
published a Pullman in New Yorker a
couple of years ago and I wrote him an
email about it saying I didn't
understand one part of it and he wrote
back saying it bothers me a lot that
this poem is not accessible and he was
engaged in a process of revision and
they sent me some change that you think
this is any better I'm not sure that the
poem was really improved by his changes
but but I know that the poem became
clearer because of his changes and it
seems to be a very meaningful comment on
his way of working that it matters to
him to be understood and I thought maybe
I know that you don't like to do this
because in your position you have to be
friendly to all forms of poetry but
there really is a situation in the
poetry world at large in which there is
a vast ocean of material that's being
written is written in the kind of
mystical or obscurantist way in which no
rational reader can make sense of it I'm
wondering if you
would be willing to say something about
sort of the condition of poetry in that
way I think I I think one never knows
what the condition of poetry is you know
the day that Elizabeth Bishop wrote at
the fish houses which I consider a great
poem it didn't say the next day or the
next week or so in Time magazine New
York Times or in poetry magazine last
week Elizabeth Bishop road at the fish
houses one of the best problems the last
30 40 years you perceive these things
over time and there's a moment at which
Stephen Vincent Benet is a very
important poet Elizabeth Bishop isn't
and then decades pass and it becomes
recast so you don't know you don't see
the scene well I do know that for many
very young people there is an available
style that's very opaque and you can see
why it is attractive because in this
opacity you seem to be tormented
profound dissatisfied with limitations
of language and it's an armored against
go Cherie it's an armored against
seeming naive it's an instant access to
sophistication and it's a to effective
defense you perfect a way of writing
that seems to solve all problems and
this was true some winters disciples who
wrote skill will must crust that also is
a kind of a defense and I think that to
do an art you need to be vulnerable
especially when you're young you need to
be gauche how can you ever get further
if you don't manifest your go Cherie and
so you think it's you say its protective
Robert the term yeah I think so i think
you can see why especially when there's
lots and lots of people want to write
poetry which is a good thing but then
they're afraid of being klutzy you I
know that terror very well myself and if
there's an available style that protects
you against seeming clumsy or unsure
uncertain it's a great trend temptation
very attractive I think you must risk
seeming stupid and I feel it every time
I write the
I am risking see me stupid sad and
whatever bad thing you're worried about
banal you know I was excessively
defensive when this gentleman asked me
about the humanistic meaning of this
vibe because I'm thinking on the one
hand do I want it too glibly say we must
be humanists and not the robots and the
other hand or I want to make to you can
see that in either way there's a there's
a pitfall and you have to confront your
own ambivalence and believe me it's much
worse for me than for a 20 year old 19
or 20 year old kid writes something
stupid so it's 90 I I you know you wrote
something stupid I write something
stupid Robert [ __ ] Pinsky know
something stood so if anybody at all is
heard of you the stakes go up and if you
don't feel any of that for me anyway I
know you're right it there are times
when you say it's easy but you have to
feel some of that and I think that all
styles of the period probably always
have an element in them of here's a way
to seem to have done and right now it's
a way to see not to have it's a way to
defend yourself very easy very veiled
instant sophistication have read very
much and you can seem could
sophisticated by adopting this manner
that okay that was good it wasn't it
wasn't exactly an answer to the question
is a Thorburn store was but we were
hoping he I don't know if we need this
we were the two guys at Stanford with
the two guys in Stanford from New Jersey
he had gone to Princeton icon to Rutgers
and they actually got us mixed up a lot
i've been very proud of this most of my
life people it confuses we didn't look
particularly like Sam but we were the
two smart guys from New Jersey or
something and they were mostly
Westerners and one day I was stopped at
a traffic light my car and a carful a
convertible full of fellow graduate
students
pulled up and as the light was changing
one of the women in the car was very
closely looked at me and said well hello
mr. laubrain Thorburn well I can't help
that story actually I do have a story
about our confusion though it didn't
maybe it does top it well when we when
we care that when we came out of
graduate school we went for interviews
at various places this is an impossible
situation for contemporary academics to
imagine but there were hundreds of jobs
available we were there we were very
sought after we were offered many jobs
the University of Chicago offered me a
job which I turned down to go to Yale
the University of Chicago called Robert
and offered him a job and they said
delivered it was Harvard they called a
called Robert and they said to Robert
well you can have this job we'd like you
to come there to write about my
dissertation topic the Harvard was
confusing I got a letter from the
superior that he refused them on this
space it was actually come here and
among other things we'd like you to
teach one of your favorite subjects
perhaps Conrad in the sea tale which I
had purchased my Fit which was my
dissertation this reinforced what
winters said to me winters said don't
take the job at Yale or at Harvard those
faces art reps for young people and then
when i read the Conrad thing I said
maybe he's right so now i can say people
so you teach your Harvard right say no
my only relation to Harvard was I want
to turn to job down it is actually
probably a rare a group of people who
can say they turned the job down at
Harvard then then people who have
accepted jobs it's an impressive thing
Robert Robert what am I almost my
credentials 11 of one of Roberts most
remarkable credentials well I think well
I I there was a poem of Roberts I was
hoping to have him read at a conclusion
so a couple more questions if there are
any and then I think I'd like Robert do
you have copies of the chat book with
you how did you do at the door sure okay
any final questions or comments there's
a the chapbook that is about to appear
in a month or two your question here yes
good 20 minutes ago oversight of the
line that had to do it do it memory and
I've been watching our culture well
forever or my version forever 53 years
and but i've really noticed over the
last 15 to 20 years what an odd way and
I think it's not all anglo-saxon
cultures I think it's particularly
American this very weird relationship we
have with memory actually I'm struck by
more our relationship to forgetting and
I just wondered if you could speak to
that because the when you said or you
describe the moment when someone's words
have impacted you enough that you want
to say those same words again that's a
moment that I recognized in my life not
just from reading but I remember
specific moments hundreds of them when
my brother or a friends said something
that we're so perfect that I've repeated
it a hundred times and it's it's part of
the meaningfulness of my own life and I
feel at the same time I look around me
and get the feeling that I'm in a
culture that's desperate to forget as
much as it can and obliterate as much as
it can and I can't quite pull that all
together and I'm wondering how you do I
fought over I thought of calling my new
manuscript the book of forgetting and a
line and one of the poems has to do with
forgetting being a form of memory
forgetting is a particularly disturbing
form of memory I'm going to in response
to your question I'm going to read a
poem other than one David wanted me to
read I'll read the other one as well oh
gosh are we I'll read both this is a
poem that is probably at the far end of
being hard to understand for some of my
friends I'm still not sure what I'm
going to entitle it it's this phenom
of things being forgotten culturally
poor Bert Williams WC Fields eddie
cantor all those early comics the
Ziegfeld comic said the most inventive
the best writer the best performer was
Bert Williams Bert Williams was a black
man he could only work in blackface he
tried working without the blackface he
was a rather light-skinned black man and
it didn't work for him that was not a
demeaning characters characters you can
on the web you can pick up things like
you can you can buy him singing his song
nobody when I'm in trouble I know that
how I can rely on nobody anyway he's
just one example and cultural forgetting
as well as personal forgetting is
something I'm interested in and I think
in a first draft is poems called I've
never heard of one of my friends
suggested calling it but it's now the
title Louie Louie but probably a lot of
people under a certain age even have
forgotten Louie Louie and it's that
phenomena and then their expressions
people forget how many people here have
ever heard the expression white Catholic
one person how many people have ever
heard the expression white June nobody
you can guess what they mean though
right somebody who seems more like a
wasp but they happen to be Jewish or
Catholic i was at Notre Dame when I for
I had heard white Jew since I was a
child at Notre Dame I was talking to a
kid who explained that his parents were
on the board of the symphony in the
Midwestern city he came from and he said
I'm what you call a white Catholic that
is it's not a working class family it's
a very tennis-playing kind of family
I'll read this poem that i read the poem
door the date is that's okay good plan I
have heard of black Irish but I never
heard of white Catholic or white Jew I
have
of his poetry popular but I never heard
of Lawrence Welk Grove Sid Caesar off
television I had heard of Kwanzaa but i
have never heard of bert williams i have
never heard of Will Rogers or Roger
Williams or Buck Rogers or pearl buck or
Frank bucket Yale or Frank buck or Frank
Merriwell at Yale I have heard of Yale
but I never heard of George W Bush I
have heard of Harvard but I never heard
of numerous clauses which sounds to me
like some kind of pig latin how many
people here know what numerous closest
is too he's a secret number that until a
couple of decades ago the secret
percentage of jubie's jews that were
loud into Yale or Harvard or Princeton
numerous clauses I have heard of Yale by
never heard of George W Bush I've heard
of Harvard but I never heard of numerous
classes which sounds to me like some
kind of pig latin I have heard of the
pig boy I have never heard of the
Beastie Boys or the Scottsboro Boys how
many people here have heard of the
scottsboro boys almost a third just a
half I had heard of the Beastie Boys or
the Scottsboro Boys I've never heard of
the Beastie Boys or the scottsboro boys
but i have heard singing boys what they
were called i forget i have never heard
America singing but I have heard of I
hear america singing I think it must
have been a book we had in school I
forget I suppose it's a poem spawns to
the poems of person I'm school in the
person who I'm scolding but it's also
the person of myself there's a perverse
Pinsky who comes out in poems like this
i think in one of his poems he has one
poem that sort of is a disobedient
adolescent it's an angry adolescent of
the poems
calls itself I feel like I basically
remained in angry adolescent which I
certainly was and it's amazing that some
of it goes down should I close with this
yes maybe get maybe give it back to
explain where it comes in there's a
sequence of poems that are it's called
it's lose what the chat book would be it
will be this come back tonight it's
called first thing to hand first things
to hand and the theory the is that the
first thing I touch has to be the
occasion for a poem so it would be my US
airways prefer different miles card and
you would talk about plastic and this
one is before they put the magnetic
strip on it it's delaminating and the
layers of what's happening to labor and
health plans from airlines that whoever
was in charge of laminating this the
person who invented it I hope they made
money but it's the clear plastic that
makes it glossy as delaminate blah blah
blah and the point is not ordinary life
is so interesting but that the occasion
for a poem is never really its subject
otra Nightingale is not a better bird
sailing to byzantium is not about
Byzantium they're about all the things
Keats felt about life that day all the
things that the Yates was feeling about
life that day and if each of us wrote a
poem about the little plastic card each
poem would express the personality and
the obsessions and the concerns of that
person or even just wrote a paragraph
describing it we would be writing the
things that matter to us so there's a
poem called book this one called
newspaper there's one called jar of pens
there's one called other hand it's the
next thing you touch and what time we
were supposed to finish right now when
you finish this this is door door the
cat cries for me from the other side it
is beyond her to work this device that I
open
cross and clothes with such ease when I
mean to work it's four panels form
across the rude impaling gatepost of
redemption the rod a dividing Pike or
pal mounted and hinged to swing between
one place and another meow between the
January vulva of birth and the January
of death's door there are so many to
negotiate closed or from oak or a jar
valve of attention Oh kitty if the doors
of perception were cleansed all things
would appear as they are infinite come
in darling growls comfortably near my
feet I will click the barrier closed
again behind you Oh sister will fellow
mortal here we are
you